[Music]
william dumb i'm sitting four feet to
your left wearing a pair of shorts
because it's roasting hot in los angeles
i just thought i'd give you a treat and
let you see my legs lovely lovely hairy
legs um
it's so hot in england right now that
the
runway at luton airport melted and the
planes couldn't land they've now updated
that that london has melted
amazing
40 degrees celsius which i think they're
saying is breaking records all over the
place was that in a fun height
i think it's pushing into your kind of
103 104 type verbs it's hot
how do you work that i don't i don't
know if it's the right time again in
this storm but i do have problems with
centigrade and fahrenheit right okay go
on because i grew up in germany where
they do centigrade and then i had to
move to the united states where they do
fahrenheit i think i'll mix it up
because centigrade there's a one that
goes from zero to a hundred right no
that's fahrenheit really yeah centigrade
is you know the top of it is like 40 is
roasting hot whereas obviously in
fahrenheit 105 110 is really hot so what
is boiling water
100 degrees celsius
so that's good nothing to do with
certain degree door family yeah celsius
that's another way of taking temperature
but isn't that a weird thing where isn't
100 degrees
centigrade the same as 100 degrees
fahrenheit there's something that's as
well this is what i get confused about
someone at home can tell us about this
water freezes at zero degrees celsius
celsius it boils at a hundred degrees
celsius so when it's
80 degrees here and it's really hot it's
not that high 80 degrees but yeah heart
like when it's 90 90 degrees yeah yeah
when that 92 gets to 100
that boil water that's fahrenheit
you would need the celsius which a hot
day in celsius is like 35. so that needs
to get needs to get to 100 before it
will boil water
and i mean if you're walking around in
100 degrees celsius you're dead
cause it'll boil you as well we're
almost because we're 76 percent white
right
it is confusing that thing so celsius is
the same as centigrade
um
i'm not gonna say
whether i know that or not i don't i
don't think so i have never known you to
say that you didn't know something yeah
i don't know
i could guess
no
well let me guess all right i feel like
celsius you send your last snake there
fahrenheit i think that celsius is a way
of grading
temperature of the air whereas
centigrade is a way of gauging
temperature of liquid
so when liquid
when liquid becomes air
what uh when liquid becomes gas that
brain right when it becomes gas at 100
degrees
changes from celsius to centigrade
oh so we've moved into a strange place
here anyway if there's anyone out there
that wants to come on the show and talk
to us about things like that so here's
here but i also do this okay with the
fahrenheit celsius thing because i
in germany they do centigrade and in the
states they do fahrenheit i kind of know
that 90 degrees fahrenheit is a hot day
in the same way that 30 degrees celsius
is a hot day and then you can kind of
gauge it from there and see it was
freezing
yeah
see because do i mix up fahrenheit and
and sales it seems like you did earlier
on because i
i like to talk when it's a hot day i
like saying it's 85 oh it's 90 degrees
but when it's a really cold day i like
to say it's freezing it's zero degrees
all right that's celsius because a
really cold day in fahrenheit would be
you know in your 40s something like that
so i'll mix them up then yeah you do a
hot day fahrenheit a cold day celsius
all right hot d fahrenheit gold day
celsius it be a meteorologist that comes
on to tell us about things like that
like a like a educated weatherman or
whether woman
i think that's a good idea actually
there's a great line in that uh
okay film with sandra bullock about um
her being a novelist where she asks uh
brad pitt how come he's so handsome and
he says uh my father was a weatherman i
thought that was a great line because in
the united states uh most weather men
are quite handsome whereas i don't think
that's the same in britain is it i mean
i don't think so you wouldn't say
michael fish or john ketley was like you
know there was a weatherman in scotland
and he won a sort of america's got
talent
except it was the world scott weatherman
and all the weathermen of the world did
the competition to become the weatherman
in l.a
and he won it but is that
how would they are they grading it on
his expertise with
rain and moisture in the air in
temperature is it how handsome is it i
don't know
okay
peeling the onion
well should we do some housekeeping
[Music]
dominic i like this one hmm go on you
read it this was a this was a top reddit
comment yesterday and it was someday and
i tried to explain this to you before
you came on uh before we came on and you
didn't quite get it so i'm going to try
and explain it better yeah be succinct
so someone says my partner
wrongly thought that i'd never seen
lauder rings
so
he wanted to do a marathon of the
extended editions
but then this person thought
what can i say to him while we're
watching
that will really annoy him
because he thinks i've never seen it but
i have seen it all right so i'll give
you one one thing here dom
somebody said
who's called
shirabiru05 says when you're watching it
with your partner who thinks you've
never seen it says
as soon as someone else a new character
comes on the screen say do they want the
ring too
every time a new character come hell run
does he want the ring too yeah i like
that tree beard does he won the ring i
mean they all kind of want the ring but
some less so right
that was that was a bit nerdy but it's
true it was a bit geeky you went a bit
deep there like
gandalf and galadriel and these
quote-unquote good people elrond even
tree beard they kind they're all kind of
a drawn to the ring but they're aware
that they shouldn't right who who's
who's the one character
who's not in the movie that ken i didn't
really want in the ring didn't care tom
tom bomber good old tomo
give us another one john well nick
nick's
saban
nick sabanis nick nick
sabanesia hobbit what is that right
anyway hi nick said
uh you are 100 convinced that sam is
actually a bad guy who's going to
portray frodo for the moment gandalf
catches his spine you've got a really
bad feeling about him that's a good one
oh he's the bad one
be careful of him as soon as i saw him i
knew he's going to be a baddie you could
switch it as well you could be like i
like that gollum golem
he's going to he's going to save the day
which i know
in some ways
i'll tell you what
scratchy ball sack said oh yeah scratchy
ball sack said
is this a spin-off
from those hobbit movies
kind of that would deny a lot of people
so i think that's good anyone else have
something good that you could say to
pretend you've never seen the movies if
you were watching it with someone what
is something funny
that you could see yes
to
friendship onion at
castmedia.com that's cast with a k yeah
we'll put all the information as to how
to get in touch with us in these show
notes because i forget now that i'm
getting home oh i i know everything uh
if you want to get the merchandise which
is fantastic by the way yeah it makes
you very beautiful
love the hoodies i was just drinking a
coffee from the mug today
and it tasted good really nice uh then
you can get that at the
friendshiponionpodcast.com
you can leave a voicemail yeah at
speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion wow you're good we also
have a youtube channel which is the
french bunion
i don't know that one i think it's the
french onion and if you rate review and
subscribers it means we can keep making
more i was just thinking
in terms of one of these things
when it all gets hectic for frodo you
could say he should put his watch on put
put the watch on
i really like reddit i don't really know
reddit's great so for someone like you
let's say
because currently you're really into
surfing right you could go on to reddit
have your own little account
and up the top bar there you just write
in the thing that you're interested in
let's say for instance right now surfing
tips
so you put in surfing tips and it will
just show you a whole bunch of forums so
it could be like
one sentence surfing tips or videos on
surfing tips and then you just follow
them and you can keep checking them out
so for me i have like crazy animal
trivia
league of legends advice
cooking tips it's really good man i
think you'd like read it is it just
reddit.com
yeah it's an app get the app what's that
yeah free app okay um should we do a
little league of legends uh
[Laughter]
there's a new updates
hey there's the new champion you mean my
sister yeah well your sister is playing
we'll get into that in a second which is
very exciting news but there's a new uh
champion that our friend andrew played
she's got a wet she's called nyla and
she has a whip i've not played yet but
she looks good
i've not played her yet like a kind of
female aladdin if you if you will i
would say the last two months i've been
heimerdinger crazy i think you need to
get off him i can't you you're starting
to get
fully addicted to that one champion and
what if he gets banned well what about
yesterday the song no beautiful he
dreamt it you know not the grumbled eggs
yeah go on
i played them in a different skin at
least
oh yeah pool party heimerdinger pool
party rather than alien you are very
good at heimerdinger probably the best
you've ever played a champion but i do
think now
you're moving into complacency land
because you're so good at him you just
like turn it there turret there throw a
grenade doomer thing and i want you to
be challenged
do you know what's really nice about
complacency land well it's comfortable
yeah it's easy in it yeah yeah it's easy
um
there's a new uh well not new but
there's they brought about a mode that
we like we have two alts two ultimates
played that the other night and they've
got like different animated minions
different animated canon minions but
your sister margaret let's talk about
that so she was watching the other night
she's here visiting she was charmed by
your gameplay whenever a player she she
gets a chair doesn't matter what she's
doing she could be a coffee sitting in
the front room watching chopped which
she loves oh i love chopped too you're
chopped you're out get out get out
you're chopped
that that's rubbish yeah get out get out
um
she can be watching that she'll pull a
chair in really without an invitation i
wish i had a friend that would watch me
play league of legends she pills and and
she sits there and then she tells me if
somebody's coming on the map
watch out yeah yeah you you need that
have you got the freeze
you know when you've got that little
thing where you can freeze yourself
oh yeah yeah zombies
on your glass
use the freezer i stopped watching right
at the start of the game when i haven't
bought anything oh just
so she she had a little game well just
to go back a second as youngsters yeah
was your sister into
video games computer games as you know
dom i was very into my atari and i don't
remember margaret really being into the
atari she
nah she's never really been a gamer
really right but this is good for our
guest today as well yeah yeah we'll get
into this later on with our fantastic
guests a fantastic secret special guest
so um no i think at one point i think
she had a friend who had a playstation
and i think they played like the james
bond game for a little bit oh golden eye
yeah i think so i feel like that's kind
of weird
64. what's that well we gave it we can
ask her guess what a version of that
well that's good i mean she might have
just
been so charmed by the way that you play
league of legends which is gleeful and
also little high modinger how can you
not like him a dinger he's adorable he's
lovely one to two 42. hey another
um game thing here which really plays
well for today i feel as if john has
really as he organized this boy's
organized net now when he's organised
this johnny clues he's organized it well
for today which is good because normally
it's completely random where does this
quote come from
one of these days i'm going to get
organized i don't know it's from taxi
driver go on well done mm-hmm who says
it travis bickel welcome uh robert de
niro dave from michigan says or michigan
he says dom you've mentioned that you
love skyrim and billy previously
mentioned that he's been playing elder
scrolls online i was wondering if you
happen to have seen the skyrim mode that
was recently released that enables
players to play co-op skyrim
maybe you can convince elijah and sean
to play and the boys can galavant around
skyrim together
a little cough there through my
nervousness i think unfortunately we
probably have to just
give up on elijah and shown playing
video no no we're never giving up i mean
we flew back from a convention the three
of us
and elijah and i sat next to each other
on the plane because we tend to like
stay up and chat and talk silly okay
you like a glass of wine in a nap don't
you i don't uh yeah i can be bothered to
have you know i mean we talked about it
talked it out i like a gin and tonic in
a good old chat a chin wag but anyway
elijah pulled out his switch hey
no it's a gaming system all right and uh
we were playing uh games backwards and
forwards and stuff and i said to elijah
i was like man if he cause i know elijah
loves games i was like man if you still
love games and still play games you've
got to get on this league of legends
thing i know he's like hey i didn't
really like it do you think he's just
doing it because we want let me do it
and he won't do it no he's not like that
elijah is he's not maybe he's training
maybe he hasn't maybe he's maybe he's
become contrary as he's uh become a
father who knows but i feel like it's
time to kind of give it up no
and then in terms of the skyrim thing
well
see now i think this is a complementary
element of your personality bills and
then you could also look at it as
potentially
detrimental at times
you tend to jump around to different
things quite often no
i don't know of that many things that
you stick with that you're actually into
give me give me give me um we'll give
you examples of things that you stick
with no because like no things that i
jump around well like you know
martial arts no you don't do it anymore
i did that for like 20 years dom
i mean i wouldn't say that jumping
around wow football football i played
when i was six till i broke my knee
surfing surfing
20 years ago and i'm still doing it
star trek like you're watching
i've watched it since i was six and i
still watch it so i think i've made a
good point good point dumb um uh what
i'm saying is i don't think you'll
commit to playing skyrim i welcome it as
soon as i start which could be tonight
because you're coming to my house yeah
but that only got one uh video game
player though
we'll set up mine and then we'll set up
yours
i just get the feeling that you'll be
into it for a little bit and then you'll
you'll move on like like you like with
most things like start
yeah like surfing
maybe i'm using reverse psychology there
bills you just don't know
oh i love that sound you like that sound
i love it it makes me smile it's the
sound of another sail on shopify the
all-in-one commerce platform to start
run and grow your business shopify gives
entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big businesses so upstarts
startups and established businesses
alike can sell everywhere synchronize
online and in-person sales and
effortlessly stay informed scaling your
business is a journey of endless
possibility just like our business our
podcast
will shopify powers millions of
businesses from first sale to full scale
you can reach customers online and
across social networks with an ever
growing suite of channel integrations
and apps including facebook instagram
tick tock pinterest and there's many
more done
this is possibility powered by shopify
go to shopify.com onion or lowercase for
a free 14-day trial and get full access
to shopify's entire suite of features
grow your business with shopify today go
to shopify.com
onion right now shopify.com
now you've heard me talk about how
important it is to have a vpn to protect
your online privacy billy and i have
been lucky enough to be traveling all
around the united states doing jobs and
doing these conventions staying in
hotels
traveling through airports every time
we're in there we remind each other hey
are you using expressvpn get your
expressvpn so easy to do you just press
one button and that's you protected and
express vpn doesn't log your activity
online lots of cheap or free vpns they
make money by selling your data to
advertisers but expressvpn doesn't do
this they even developed a technology
trusted server that makes their vpn
servers incapable of storing any data at
all and number two speed expressvpn uses
lightweight a new vpn protocol they
engineered to make user speeds faster
than ever i've tried a lot of vpns and
it works an absolute trade
the last thing that really says
expressvpn apart is how easy it is to
use i am not good with technology billy
i'll tell you true you don't need any
technical skills to set it up just fire
up the app tap one button it goes from
red to green and you're in that's it
even your grandparents could do it so
protect yourself with the vpn that we
use and trust
use our link expressvpn.com
onion today and get an extra
three months free on a one year package
wow three months free on a one year
package that's expressvpn.com
onion visit expressvpn.com
onion to learn more
hey we should throw out a little bit of
uh um info about these upcoming uh
conventions that we're doing because
we've only got two left i don't know
when this one comes out well let's cover
ourselves and say both john's giving us
the thumbs up there right so coming up
next a wonderful visit to boston boston
colorado um no
boston
yeah i i don't know what state that is
it's in the good old state of uh boston
boston's in boston it's not boston
illinois
long island long island near rhode
island holy island
on the east coast
um east coast near new york boston we're
doing a live live
friendship onion on sunday the
the boston convention 13th
14th the 14th i can find off i'll tell
you what else boston on the 14th of
august we're doing a live friendship
onion get your tickets uh at the link
below hey you're right i just checked
you right i know and then two weeks
after that we actually leave the country
we we leave the united states of usa the
first international the friendship onion
podcast live and we head to toronto
which the locals say toronto toronto
toronto and we're doing another live
friendship onion podcast on the 28th of
august
and you can get all of your ticket
information and you can buy it at
fan expo and then put in the c that
we're going to so fan expo boston fan
expo toronto will be in local food
we'll be singing and dancing great fun
all this stuff that you like in a
friendship i didn't twist it maybe a
riddle we're doing it live
so um here's the question dom okay i'm
gonna actually equate you here oh good i
like a quiz because i don't know if you
know the answer to this
uh it's not states in in canada
there's no states in canada it's not
united states of canada
what is the area is called provinces how
many are there
do you know and can you name this cause
i'll just say this about billy and he
does this all the time
billy will ask a question and he'll make
out like he knows the answer and if you
get the answer right he'll go yes and if
you say i don't know the answer what is
it he'll go i don't know so i'm going to
ask him now do you know the answer
yes okay i know some of them do yeah
yeah i mean canada's a very big country
but i think the provinces are way bigger
than the united states right
i'm gonna make a guess of
17. i'm going to say less wow i'm going
to see
seven
wow there's some big provinces johnny
clues
how many provinces are in
the country of canada okay i didn't even
know that they were called provinces so
i got to google this province is indeed
well he's why he's gone let's try and
name them do you know any british
colombia nice
uh nova scotia great you've been to that
one yeah saskatchewan
or is that a city
i don't know er
quebec
that might be a city as well um
oh maybe you're right maybe that is i
think it's yeah um well where is
montreal what part of
obviously that was quebec
french speaking canada yeah and then
what's the west coast what would the
west coast be
like where toronto is uh no further um
with that other place oh no if we're
closer towards it cold with the ice
right
west coast island
baffin no
well they make they make a lot of tv
shows they're now the cw shows uh
vancouver yes yeah that's british
columbia that's british columbia that's
how i knew it john knows the answer
there are ten provinces i was close up
and there's actually also three
territories oh that gets up to you're
closer yeah
give us the ten
but i have to okay oh god here we go
come on johnny okay
on the spot here all right here we go
starting from uh the north west i'll go
counter clockwise good idea
first one
yukon
yukon right second one british columbia
right you got that one number three
alberta uh
[Music]
ontario
all right this is where it gets
confusing because i don't know which
ones of these are territories versus
provinces i think this is a province new
brunswick yes as
nova scotia yes billy's been prince
edward island yes yes newfoundland
newfoundland
nunavut
none of it none of it i know i don't
know the provinces and i'll have none of
it yeah new finland northwest
territories
thank you thank you john
the last one was a kind of bummer
well it's incredible it's good well done
all right well let's bring on our
fantastic guest after i was talking
about games a lot today which i i'm
enjoying to be honest dom we have a
fantastic guest who knows a lot about
retro games and retro computing and all
those kind of things
and uh
i'm gonna have a go at the second name
please
clint basinger um what do you think the
thing i was he's
he's basically the guy behind lazy game
reviews
hello clint
greetings how are you i am doing just
fine how are you very good we're good
man do you want do you want to do a
little introduction hey clinton yeah
clinton
i'll do a little blurb about you and
then you can maybe fill in the gaps
because it's only a it's a it's a
four-line
summation of clint's entire life and i
think there's more to the man than that
well give us
give us the four lines and give us a in
our style though
that will make us fall in love with both
you and clinton oh okay i'll try my best
here we go clint
clint basinger is the guy behind lazy
game reviews a youtube show that began
in 2009 dedicated to revisiting retro
technology in the history of computing
it has a micro compressor
hang on what what has a micro effect has
a micro processor uh i've ruined it it
measures
four lines i'm backing up hang on there
we go clint
if
it has a micro processor a keyboard and
comes in beige or wood grain chances are
it'll be an
ltr thing at some point clint basinger
ladies and gentlemen hi clint hello
welcome lazy game reviews how are you
yes yeah i'm doing just fine great to be
here tell us what you've been doing this
morning and please tell us you've been
playing galaxia and defender and having
a great time
i was actually just playing uh galaga
yesterday on a recently sort of
reassembled arcade machine of mine but
uh yeah today it's been mostly
recording uh footage for random computer
stuff that i know i'm going to cover at
some point i just don't know when
so you like computers uh clint and you
like games but you have more of a i'm
going to drop a little french word here
if you don't mind
ponchon
for old-school games atari type vibe is
that the idea
yes yeah pretty much um sort of as the
summary said if it has a wood grain on
it like an old atari i've actually got
one right there behind me in the screen
and then yeah an apple ii over there and
you know anywhere from sort of 1978 to
1998 that's kind of the you know the
really goldilocks zone for my interests
i would say will you play modern games
or are you just not into the modern game
thing
yeah i'm very much into the modern stuff
too um it's kind of uh
the goal i guess of my own channel and
just covering the kind of older stuff is
looking at
where we've been and then comparing that
contrasting that and following the
history of that to where we are now and
then you know whenever it makes sense to
go into the more modern stuff
either on the channel or on my own um
yeah that's fun too because it's all
about context
so what what is the name of the atari
with the wood grain and the cartridges
so that original one
1977 was the atari video computer system
more well-known probably is the 2600
26 well here's my here's my story of
that one clint that was my childhood
that game that gaming system and i had
relatives who lived in detroit
michigan
and obviously i grew up in in scotland
so the the little cartridges with the
games you know space invader whatever
were expensive
see they were
as a guest on
they were
15 pounds oh is that is that for are you
uh
considering inflation there or not i'm
not considering anything i just threw an
a number out there because 15 pounds
doesn't seem that expensive to me but
back in 1977 so you're not considering
inflation say there were 15 pounds
when you go to detroit michigan
they were like two pounds
and i remember every time i went to
detroit we'd buy all the games
but most of them wouldn't work
they when you put it in the cartridge
into the machine but here's what i did
clint
if you opened up the and maybe you can
explain this to me why this would be if
you opened up the box
and took out the actual chip
like when you when you flicked open the
box it was basically just like a piece
of plastic
and a kind of shape like that that would
open up the the thing and then i had
like a little chip so if i put that
plastic in and then just put the chip in
then the game would work well how do you
work that out would you just get
frustrated one day and try it i must
have done because obviously there wasn't
internet no one told me how to do that
incredible but it like the first time i
brought them home it wouldn't work and
then somehow
i managed i don't know how i knew that
and i opened up so i had all the games
were just little chips
what do you think of that
that sounds actually pretty reasonable
it's not far off from what you might do
to to get it working now because it's
all about making physical contact
between those little uh gold leaf edges
that it has on there and you need to get
proper friction and you know a bit of a
continuity between the electronics of
the game console and the electronics the
chips and everything inside that
connects straight through this little
edge connector and there's only so many
pins
on that connector and if not every
single one of them was exactly in there
so sometimes you bend things out of
shape sometimes you stuff things in
there people would blow in there and
they'd you'd try all kinds of hair
dryers
someone would say if it's not working
just put a hot hair dryer on it but oh
that that gaming system for years of my
childhood was just
when you got a new game i can i can i
can feel the feeling just know the
excitement yeah of getting that cart a
new cartridge and
and what was your old what was the top
of most of the proper most i mean
i love space invaders and i i seem to
remember at 132 different versions which
was basically 132 versions of the same
game yeah some of the versions were just
crazy one one
one of the controllers would move it
left the other one would move it right
and just just stupid versions of the
same game space invader is the one where
you've got the little barriers above and
you have to hide yeah and a chunk chunk
chunk chunk and they get lower and lower
chunk chunk chunk
love that
i loved adventure when we first got it
that seemed like cutting edge
when that came out
but here's i'm getting really excited
about this because i've taken myself
back to my childhood here clint but
before i got the atari i remember going
to the stores to to try the game
and one of the stores was a quite a
high-end electric store and they had a
gaming system called activision
perhaps the in television yeah in
television had some uh fantastic sports
games including soccer games i wonder if
in a in britain it was called activision
there's a question for you clinton
maybe i actually don't
no i have an in television right here
just they look like that that's the
bugger that's the bad with this spinning
thing nice well did you have one of
those
no
i remember the atari cost a hundred
that's it
cost a hundred and the activision or
intelligent vision
cost 200. oh and my mum just would not
go to 200 and i remember oh the thought
of having that gaming system in your
house but then you'd have two you'd be
spoiled no it was one or the other dog
oh i didn't have either what did you
have didn't have it didn't have any you
didn't have a gaming system didn't have
a gaming system that's probably why
you're so into gaming now probably but
we i think my brother was into computers
more than me and the first time we got
we didn't get a gaming system but we got
a computer because my dad said well you
can use it for school as well i think i
was probably 13 or something like that
what computer was that do you know
spectrum plus three
do you know what that is
clint yeah made uh sinclair the uh
certified sinclair systems they had all
those the zx spectrums the 48k and the
plus yeah one plus three the one two was
a cassette and the plus three was a
floppy disk or a compact disc which was
like really
zx81 was that the first one
there was the zx80 i believe was their
their first it was like um
a slightly i mean they were both really
really primitive but
that one in particular
they had that one in 18 or 1980 and then
81 was the zx81 those both came kind of
back to back before moving on to the
spectrum and that's when they added
color
right yeah exactly well with all of
these options out there currently clint
in the gaming arena which has exploded
not only you know with what we've all
gone through with everyone being in
isolation but just the advances in
computer science and stuff and you
finding a real kind of charm in
that era of gaming for someone who
doesn't play games how would you pitch
those type of games where nowadays the
technology allows you to you know
experience incredible worlds and
incredible graphics and sounds and stuff
and clearly these games are a little bit
more rudimentary but what's the charm in
those games for you
a lot of the charm definitely comes from
a mixture of imagination and then just
not having as much to worry about
visually or sound wise or control wise
or anything often it was just one button
a joystick and that was about it so if
you were maybe in the mood for something
that's much more pick up and play you
can just
jump in and jump out within five minutes
and have your good feel of that title
and i say that that's uh you know that's
that's one of my go-to's
constantly for you know things like uh
galaga or any of these atari games and
television games because you don't have
to commit too much to them and
increasingly for me anyway you know
you end up with less and less time as
life goes on
uh in some cases so if you just uh need
a quick fix it's often a great way to do
that but you know there's also just the
imagination factor of having these such
simple worlds to explore like adventure
you were mentioning that still can get
your attention you know just going
through these
extremely simple mazes but you start
filling in the dots and all of a sudden
that block is a person and that other
little thing is a sword and that other
bit is a magical treasure and you know
if you let yourself
let go perhaps it's uh yeah it's a fun
escape and finding the easter eggs in
adventureland in adventures obviously
great as well you know i remember my
brother had a when we were a little bit
older my brother had a little
miss pac-man
arcade machine that was about this big
it only played miss pac-man
and we got so good at it that to clear
the screen we would eat all of the
pills apart from the magic pills which
turned the ghosts into things that
batman could eat so then you'd go and
you'd hit all four of the magic pills
and then chase the ghost and kill them
all before the next level and i tried
that recently and i couldn't get
anywhere near to completing the screen
and keeping the things there so it's
crazy what you get good at is a little
yeah yeah you practice something you get
good at it yeah
what about that game remember anything
else
yeah exactly do you remember the
olympics game where you had to like
waggle the joystick backwards and
forwards and then when you're running
you have to tap them both next to each
other oh breaking your nails and stuff
and see i was watching you i was
watching your your show the lazy game
review and you were
you you got an old i think it was a no
it wasn't a gallagher it was the one
where you fly through
uh oh i forget the name of it now
but yeah yeah the one i recently got i
got a a ridden two machine
red and that's right yeah
well see those machines because i think
that watching you do it there's
obviously a sort of joy
in
looking back historically oh this is
this machine from that time and that
came from japan and blah blah and
i i was wondering when i was watching it
because
certainly when i was watching it you
didn't open it up how much of that
machine
had anything in it
very little for the most part yeah those
arcade machines you'll get a board
that's
you know maybe as big as like a placemat
or something it's not very much and then
that's going to run the entire machine
most of it is just empty there's wood
surrounding and then there's the monitor
speakers and some basic input controls
but you know if it's a
it's it's just a lot of wood
primarily just the joy of seeing that
shape isn't it
like from yeah when you used to go in
arcade and there'd be a brand new game
there you know asteroids or something
and
and and basically they just made these
boxes and then fitted other games into
it is that right
that's correct yeah especially the the
one that i happened to pick up was a
dynamo hs5 from 1988 and they used that
thing all throughout uh into the
mid to late 90s and just if you were an
arcade operator you would buy this
cabinet from the manufacturer or
game publisher or somebody like that it
might come with something in it or you
could just get them completely empty and
they're really just meant almost like a
modern pc where you just get the case
and then you put whatever you want to in
there yeah so instead of that
being able to run a lot of different
things in there you might have one game
or two games at most that you could run
and then you just swap the boards out
everything else mostly remained the same
and how much would something like that
cost also how much is that buggy in the
window but the one with the way too yeah
let's find that out too at the same time
no like if i say i wanted a gallagher
which i'm sure was called galaxia and
and was it there were two of them yeah
yeah
a couple of years before galagas the
same developer and everything so they're
very very similar very similar oh yeah
and i did watch you playing that and you
look very skilled to be honest clint
now what's new space invaders in galaga
space invaders got the little barriers
what's gallagher galago they come and
they're like this and then
they come at you
in a ship that can move yeah you can go
up a bit and come back a bit
but you're getting a little bit
everything you get the space bugs it's
more bug-shaped things coming down from
space yeah i think that's harder than
space invaders it's actually more fun as
well is it
but how much would that cost say say i
wanted one of them for the house i'm
just wondering because my birthday's
coming up and my good friends
i'm very generous
so i i the most recent galaga cabinet
that i saw was selling for fourteen
hundred dollars oh no no no
no i was thinking of getting you like a
pair of socks or something like that
fourteen hundred dollars doesn't seem
much that's my joy i think maybe for you
could buy back your childhood right you
could fulfill the the wishes of being
your own arcade owner and you can even
get uh you can create your own tokens
for instance and insert those in there
you can have your facebook
just how about that you get the machine
i'll get the tokens
because we used to do that clint me and
my friends we had to get a bus
to the to the um arcade and we'd have a
pound each we actually called it going
for a pound shuffle oh lovely and we go
and we take that pound and we get 10 p's
and i got you 10 games 10 goes yeah and
then that's us back home again on the
bus that's a lot of fun and it was
wonderful
uh what about centipede i'd like to have
a centipede game that was a great game
yeah is it different from the
human-centered paid game yeah
that game doesn't have any correlation
between the film and just checking no
but that was a good game what year was
that clint
i want to say it was 82 but i would have
to check on that they were all sort of
between 1980 to 83 is what we've mostly
been discussing is that like snake are
you linking together little pieces and
you're getting bigger and bigger no
you're shooting you're shooting a
centipede you know what i said it's made
from lots of little bits she wants you
all the bits
and then before he leaves i don't know
is that mushrooms he leaves i don't know
mushrooms yeah
little mushrooms and little spiders
floating around trying to catch it and
stuff so oh it's a shame that was a
killer
seems to be my my uh
sweet spot huh for games
yeah i mean that was also you know when
the atari and television were really
going crazy and that's when the games
were the cheapest at least here in the
u.s because they uh
they were creating so many of them that
the video game industry almost
completely disappeared and they crashed
in 83 at least here do you have the
thing we have the et game clint
i sure do certainly you have to have
that consistently thought of as the
worst computer game ever is it is that
the um is that the game that destroyed
the atari
it's often uh the most
go-to kind of escape coupe uh scapegoat
title it's maybe you know just a symptom
of a very much larger problem that was
happening but uh it was yeah it's
certainly not a great game let's put it
that way hmm and a great movie
unfortunately so they don't yeah
if we if we fast forward through into
like the not not too distant past have
you played
uh the lord of the rings games clint
many of them yes
only ones in particular that stand out
because i i played the one i think i
played the return of the king game
that's the one that we're in
the return of the king was the one that
yeah my brother and i played the most uh
we had a co-op you know we'd both get a
controller and just go through there you
know
i think it was usually uh aragorn and
gimli playing but we were just going
through and that one ah yeah i had the
most fun with that one and also the uh
battle for middle earth games those were
all my other favorites the strategy
titles so oh i've not played those but i
did like the return of the king game and
yeah we're like bonus
characters right so if you complete the
game you unlock us i think did you ever
play as us clint i wish no but i don't
remember that being an option so it
would make sense if you were unlockable
instead
i think i would definitely have to do
that at some point it's a nice little
extra bonus for completion we have
expert uh stone throwing skills in that
game and that's about all really yeah
now what about league of legends because
i don't know if you know but billy and i
billy and i play league of legends quite
a lot have you have you ever played
league of legends
i i never have no for me it was always
um you know like battlefield middle
earth was sort of the real time strategy
era that i was really into sort of the
in the early 2000s then from what i
gather league of legends is less
real-time strategy and more like
individual characters as opposed to
large groups of armies right so i've
never really got one it's basically
capture the flag
yeah
little champions
so what what got you um interested and
involved
in sort of more retro
is it are you the same as me were you a
huge lover of it at the time and then
just thought i'll go back and revisit
yeah it kind of uh it started that way
and then it sort of grew out of control
and now i'm surrounded by it everywhere
it really began with uh
you know just remembering these things
from childhood seeing them at friends
houses cousins houses and playing them
there but never really having much at
home
and then you know seeing things in
stores and always you know i was just
out of reach and you know you could
maybe afford a couple of games a year
for the pc primarily i grew up as a
computer gamer but
yeah as uh i got a little older and you
know started making my own money and
occasionally i would find old computers
at thrift stores primarily and the the
games to go along with them and that was
back when they were still more
affordable you know you could get a
computer for a couple of bucks as
opposed to hundreds now so
the uh the retro scene has really
exploded but thankfully i got into it
before
it did any of that and now yeah it's uh
turned into a career talking about them
well yeah because i'm looking at your
channel and it's huge
it shows you the interest that people
really want to watch this stuff and
learn about it
i will give you a thousand points
which is quite a lot of points in this
game oh yeah
a thousand points if you have
the my first computer and
500 points if you even know what it is
glenn my first computer was called a
dragon 32
uh yes i actually have a uh one that
they released it here as the tano dragon
and it's the the same thing nice kind of
beigey cream case with black keys and uh
starts up with sort of a green
background and everything for where you
could type in to load programs and such
yeah here it was the taino dragon was a
welsh computer if i recall
so
computer a thousand points wow yeah
there you go
i remember the welsh pcs out there
no and there's a there's a store in the
uk
called boots
and it's sort of like a cvs you know
it's the chemist i believe burt's the
chemist exactly yeah and boots the
chemist sold the dragon 32.
it was the weirdest
do you remember at that time
you there was always a choice to be made
you get a vhs or you get a betamax
and then whatever one you chose the
other one
you know you either chose the right one
or the wrong one but one of them was
going to disappear
and all my friends got the zx 80 or 81
and i got the dragon 32 and the dragon
32 disappeared and there was no
nothing i know
no one had i'm i'm really shocked that
you've heard of that clint yeah that's
amazing that sort that that came and
went it was a very brief moment in time
that it was even advertised at all and
then uh what was a fascinating story
with that so
the us distributor for them um ended up
with this massive shipment because
dragon you know went out of business and
everything and then there were just tons
of them on pallets and they ended up in
a warehouse for
25 30 years
and there were just unsold brand new
inbox dragons sitting in a warehouse in
california up until around 2012 or so
and uh they finally started selling them
and i ended up getting one of those uh
new invites and that's how i got my
dragon was uh was the old stock that
just never saw billy you should get one
see if he can get one glenn glenn as i
said it's my birthday coming up on the
28th of august dragon 32 28th of august
by the way is when we are doing a live
friendship on youtube in toronto
on my birthday mm-hmm if clint
arrived from north carolina to toronto
with a dragon thirty-two that's amazing
was it clint if you don't mind me saying
was it an expensive system i wouldn't
listen to this earmuffs william
was it it was actually extremely cheap
back then because nobody had heard of it
nobody knew what it was i think they've
gone up a bit now how much would you i
don't think very much
i actually don't know i i haven't looked
in a long time because uh yeah i've
already got mine right so what would you
say
in the history of gaming systems what
would you say
would
fetch the highest value now if it was in
mint condition
to sell
oh dear uh probably
if we're talking released systems
because there are some systems that go
for almost
hundreds and hundreds of thousands but
those are prototype systems like the
nintendo playstation and things like
that they had a weird collaboration back
in the day where they
made a couple of systems and a couple of
them eventually found themselves into
the way of collectors that's so self for
crazy money but uh you know those were
never actually released
so i think currently probably it would
be like a sealed
fully intact nintendo of some kind
whether it would be an nes or a
nintendo 64 or something seems to be
really hot at the moment but it would
have to be you know pristine there's a
lot of commission yeah
yeah people can go over the finest
details of those i'm trying to think
about how this happened because i know
that sean and elijah got one too did i
think maybe we visited playstation or ea
but we were all given
a test playstation do you remember a
test playstation
uh there were some of those yeah they
came in different colors sometimes
green or something and they were they
were kind of chipped so that you didn't
have to you could buy games from all
regions and it would play in all regions
yeah i still have mine i wonder how much
that's worth a test playstation i will
give you 12 to 15 dollars for that oh
i'll take it okay
and in terms of that that would be
awesome in terms of where where because
you obviously spend a lot of your time
talking about uh
games and gaming systems where do you
think
games are going clint like if you were
to fast forward you know 10 15 20 years
into the future what can we expect from
our games do you think
i i think i'm somewhat cynical on the
whole uh current gaming situation in
terms of um
the micro transactions and little things
that are added to games to make them
sort of always online and you know i'm
very much a proponent of
being able to own
what i own and not haven't taken away
later on if say the servers go down or
something like that i think there's
there's a lot of that happening right
now and uh that's unfortunate but
i'm also hopeful as well you know to get
more and more involved
kind of games or just different ways to
play
my favorite games you know so for
instance i just got a steam deck
recently and that thing is
wonderful for just
reinvigorating the pc games and even
console games just on the go it's just a
full-on pc in the palm of your hands
what's this type of stuff
elijah and i were talking about that
you were napping you did a glass of wine
you were sleeping i don't know what a
steam deck is clint over to you
all right so the steam deck is
effectively a linux based personal
computer system it runs a lot of other
things too but it's what it comes with
made by the valve
folks
uh in seattle in that area and they uh
got it to where it basically can
function as an all-in-one system if you
do a little bit of tweaking but out of
the box you know it's got a touch screen
uh controls on the side a little bit
like a nintendo switch but if you had
the power of a desktop computer in the
form factor of a switch
so they've just packed a lot of good
stuff in there and i've just loaded mine
up with emulation software so i can play
all the the classic stuff you know atari
nintendo and playstation one two three
games it'll play everything pretty much
up until the early 2000s so i've been
enjoying like you know my favorite pc
games from the 90s and early 2000s all
the way up to
i think the most recent game i've played
on there is cyberpunk so he actually
plays that wow so plays newer stuff in
old stuff too for a pretty decent price
very cool we should get that yeah let's
ask him steam good people of seattle
please tell send us a statement that's
the valve
because valve had a lot of success
making their own video games right and
then they just thought you know what
we're actually going to create a system
which is crazy i mean one of my favorite
kind of hacks in life
is getting on a long distance flight
right and you've looked through the
movies okay i think i've seen
yeah i've seen interstellar four or five
times on the plane it's not enough oh
it's a great movie and uh you don't
really want to do anything and then you
pull out your uh nintendo
[Laughter]
and then you can play games and everyone
else is falling asleep and you can play
games i love that so maybe we should
invest in a little steam deck each i'm
not i've i don't have a switch to pull
out
but uh is always called switch
nintendo's i don't want that one i like
the idea of this one better yeah okay a
steampunk a steam deck yeah a steam deck
yeah yeah i want to play
cyberpunk on it
you can only play three games for the
rest of your lives clint on your
steampunk
dick
what are they that's correct that's just
coming to you dawg message coming to you
yeah yeah okay
all right so the top three would have to
be uh duke nukem 3d nice dos that's up
there uh let's say
uh the sims the original one oh wow
yeah why not the sims yeah
third one
oh dear
uh well let's just let's just say
something like um
i don't know unreal tournament
i don't know what what's that what's
that
yeah that one uh 1999 so it's uh by epic
games they make fortnight now but uh
back then they had these uh early first
person shooter types it's sort of an
arena shooter uh along the lines of
a lot of people compared it to quake 3
back then i don't even know if there's
many uh games that are even very similar
now that the genre sort of died but you
know you get like 16 or so players in an
arena and you just shoot the crap out of
each other it's all death match type of
thing and capture the flag and both you
know various modes of that so online
definitely like real people or you're
against the computer
and we mostly played on a lens back in
the day with so you know everybody
brought their own computers and just set
them up in the basement or wherever uh
but it was online as well you can
actually still play it you can still
play it online it still plays on the
steam deck even so is it any is it like
an early precursor that's a fortnight
were they testing how fortnite might
work or is it slightly different
it was uh on the the ladder towards that
they're not terribly related but it is
by the same company at least
remember how addictive your son was in
fortnight and now he just doesn't play
it at all does it no he doesn't play in
in fact you know he just did the iguan
gaming computer my son he just unplugged
it all and stuck it in the corner he's
done oh
what do you think girls i remember
coming over to billy's house for a while
there and but one time in particular in
your old house
sat downstairs with you and your wife
chatting and jack came in and he was
halfway up the stairs and halfway down
and he was kind of a bit kind of antsy
and uh ali said you want to go play
fortnite don't you anyway yeah rather
than certain talk tackle uncle dawn yeah
and you went yeah you can go go play
fortnite until dinner so he went
upstairs played fortnight then we all
came down and had dinner and when dinner
was finishing he did the same thing he
got all fidgety and you said go on you
can play three more with you mate he was
full on into it well he's not that into
it well a lot a lot of that time was
kind of covered time as well so it was
the time that he got to chat to his
mates and all that but he got really
good at it three games done from any
three games i can't i can't
computer games oh because this is a
great thing see if you have a dom pick
one thing he'll always give you four so
i thought by giving him three that's
it's all you're allowed don't give me
four or five or six okay
doctors and nurses no yeah it's going to
be a tough game no no no touchy games
it's these are vid it's computer games
yeah it's not kiss cuddle or torture i
was gonna say who's in my mouth is one
of my favorite games well um
okay three games league of legends well
absolutely only because of the
brotherhood that we have the joy we've
had on there league of legends that's
two two he said league of legends twice
league of legends the elder scrolls
skyrim oh
and
ah probably fifa
oh nice well i do like fifa it's classic
man that's good yeah that's me
do you like fifa no ask me for my three
give us your three favorite computer
games keep it clean i'll need i'll need
clint to help me here actually the first
one
one of them's not league of legends
league of legends number one good for
you
number two there's a game
where you're like the moonlander
and yet and you're coming down and you
have to land on a little shelf
on the moon orlando yeah lunar landers
is it that simple yeah and different
platforms each level yeah and little
platforms and bigger and you come down
and you have to land it oh fun i would i
would choose that wow thinking back the
joy i got from that
and then my third one
even though once you've done it but i'm
just thinking the most fun i've had tuna
and this this game
i probably
10 p at a time
spent 850 000 pounds
10 pence at a time trying to finish this
game which was a laserdisc game
and you were a guy trying to save a
princess
and you had to like at one point you're
on a little river and you had to go down
and make left right turns and then you
had to swing across what was that called
that was dragon's lair zadon blue
friends
dragon's lairs oh my god tremendous
knowledge clint when i tell you that we
used to go for a pound shuffle i would
just put my whole pound into that thing
what so there was a time where you
preferred that to like gallagher and
centipede and space invader i mean you
couldn't believe it because it was like
you were a cat people would crowd around
that one too because it was such a
realistic looking thing it was like
playing a cartoon and it really was it
was the same guy who did you know the
final movies and you know secret of nam
it's the same animator
so it's you know very disney-esque
animation it was great beautiful very
very hard and looking back at it now it
was basically just timing you know hit
left there hit right there but
at the time you felt like you were in a
cartoon
you were actually a character and it was
amazing
billy and dom eat the world
well william should we eat the world oh
i'd love to no and every week we like to
uh ask our guests if there's a certain
type of food or beverage that maybe they
have a strong affiliation with maybe
they've grown up with maybe they've
recently found it and they want to tell
people about it and what have you chosen
for us this week what have you chosen
clint and why
so
i have chosen pimento cheese oh
why
and the why is uh well it's just sort of
one of those grown up with it it's very
nostalgic thing but it's also
still used on a massive number of dishes
here in north carolina so everything
from sandwiches
as a dip to just
whatever it's sort of an
all-encompassing condiment of sorts so
and now it is a cheese
but it's actually these are the few
other things added to it is that right
yeah
it can be made a few different ways but
sort of a creamy spread you know it has
pimento peppers like you'd find in the
middle of olives in there but um
sometimes people add jalapeno sometimes
not it's just shredded different cheeses
and
sometimes it can be a little spicier or
not but yeah sort of a
mayo
cheese pimento mixture so i don't know
clint if you've listened to the
friendship onion but we have a producer
here called john johnny clues and he's
one of the great great chefs a great
classic chef classic uh french uh
classical chef
and he apparently at home
has made us pimento cheese for today so
john if you have that cheese at the resi
we would love to taste your cheese john
well you join us here in the no expenses
spared uh set
for billion dollar eat the world where
we are enjoying pimento cheese william
with clint our wonderful guest hello
clint hello
hi clint we've just got it here smell
that
yeah it's okay i quite like the smell it
makes me think of uh
a picnic in a nice a nice park somewhere
and i'm wearing my shorts which i'm
doing today though yeah i got your legs
out and i could see me and you on a
lovely rug with some pimento cheese some
dry bread which uh
john has given us for this and a nice
packet of veggie wholesome crispy
crackers yes from from appleways we're
going to open that
also i'll read a little blurb here about
that
is it not good i don't like that smell
that's like glue oh it smells like
chemicals right carry on job
almost all pimento cheese recipes today
call for grated cheddar i bet it's not
real cheddar which is from the cheddar
gorge in the north of england so it's a
shame that people call fake cheddar
cheddar because the only cheddar that is
uh cheddar is from the cheddar gouche
similar to champagne william is that
true yeah from the champaign valley in
uh the champagne region of france
tremendous knowledge nothing else is a
sparkling wine anyway carry on
ah almost all pimento cheese recipes
today call for grated cheddar or a
similar firm cheese mixed with diced
pimento peppers
mayonnaise and any number of seasonings
and special ingredients many cooks are
quite adamant that you use homemade
mayonnaise while others start with fresh
red peppers and roast them themselves
the original version started out as
something quite different the marriage
of cream cheese
and canned pimentos to popular and newly
available products of the industrial
food trade so tell us about this clint
so as a young man would would your uh
parents or your aunt or someone make
this well or an uncle or an uncle
whoever it might be maybe make you some
of this you stick on some dry bread and
you get yourself on
king kong
no what was that called that game were
the barrels oh donkey kong donkey kong
that's a good game and all although i
could see clint on a massive gorilla to
be honest yeah so tell us
yeah now pretty much all of the above
all all the family members friends
anywhere really that served
something for lunch pimento cheese
sandwiches were pretty common and
literally just pimento cheese on a
sandwich sometimes you would add a meat
sometimes not other times it would just
be out on the table for sunday afternoon
lunch or something and yeah dipped in
crackers or topped on top of meats i
rather like it on
different types of fish but uh yeah
we've not actually established
geographically where where you are have
we clint whereabouts are you in the
country
see i'm uh in north carolina in the u.s
so down in the southeast uh used to live
in sort of the middle part of the state
the piedmont area and then yeah i moved
over to the western part i'm up in the
appalachian mountains now so so well i'm
sorry william i was just going to say
where are you from as a child that's
kind of a local delicacy pimento cheese
is that right
yeah it's very much known for that
anytime i've gone or you know had to had
friends down to the area and they see
pimento cheese on local menus and on top
of sandwiches and different types of
dishes that everybody just what is that
like why would you put pimentos and what
is this so it's a something i'd never
realized that was regional until uh
adulthood well let me tell you clint it
was actually in the 1870s in new york
state where farmers started making a
soft unripened cheese modeled after the
french new
newfounds
within a few decades at least five new
york companies were marketing it as
american neuf chatel
and they soon introduced cream cheese a
very uh made by mixing cream of noof
chateau curd and molding anti-blocks and
small rectangular wood forms and though
produced primarily in new york cream
cheese somehow became linked with the
city of philadelphia
and the new york based
phoenix cheese became the market leader
in its philadelphia brand cream cheese
which was later acquired by the kraft
cheese company now that's basically a
history of uh cream cheese lovely
reading which uh sometimes is used in
pimento cheese yes because in britain um
there is a very famous probably the most
famous cream cheese it's simply called
philadelphia philadelphia cream cheese
now um do you did you live near a rally
i lived uh about two and a half hours
i'm about six hours from there now yeah
all right because me and dom went there
once very close to there when i had a uh
gallstones of all things [ __ ] oh wow
there was a
natural physician there that me and um
went to see i don't know why dom went
because he didn't have ghost stones well
i'll tell you i went simply because i'm
a wonderful supportive human and my
friend was in physical uh distress and i
thought i'll take him down there and i
will go through the same amount of
physical distress that he'll go through
even though i didn't have gallstones so
all of the things that billy had like
hot baths and things being shoved
straight up his ass
stuff thrown down his throat and stuff
in his ears and clay rubbed all over him
i did that too simply as a show of
camaraderie which is another french word
of thing and um
i almost passed out didn't know at one
point at one point dom had uh a tobacco
enema
20 minutes to get the tobacco up there
and it took about three seconds to get
it out and it was he went straight to
bed we were supposed to be going to the
cinema i see er
rear window of all things well i looked
at my rear window that night and it was
a hell of a state
he couldn't get himself a bed could you
no i was in hell and there was no need
for him to do it he didn't have any
gallstones i just did it for you william
because um you know i'm one of those
great guys and all i wanted was a a
gallagher machine
a thousand four hundred dollars and then
eventually billy had his gallstones
taken out there were two absolute
whoppers about the size of mara fat peas
and i said you should definitely turn
them into earrings for your wife and
you've still not done that yet you know
one day now that you've reminded me how
supportive you were during that time i
think i'll get them made into little
necklaces that me and you could wear
yeah and then when we're old and we meet
in a bar we'll clink my stones together
and then we'll buy each other a little
drink and have a a nice sandwich and
pimento cheese that's lovely i've also
got a paste here as you know so it works
as an earring for me too well should we
have a little taste of this clint have
you got any at home or you're just going
to watch us eat in the slightly i
suppose i'm going to watch i don't have
any in here
right well what's this saying you'll
enjoy this watch
very closely
it's cheesy
definitely cheesy i mean it's um
it sticks doesn't it
it has a similar consistency to i would
say a damp peanut butter
it's about right it's like um
it's uh
it's neither hot nor cold is it
it's uh
yeah typically a room temperature sort
of spread yeah and a sort of a sort of
if i had a dull flavor quite a dull
mm-hmm sometimes
yeah that's why i like having it on on
other things you know very uh spiced up
types of sandwiches or crackers or
anything it needs it needs it needs a
slice of ham or something it needs a
fish it needs this
is a herring
clay i don't know if you've seen this
phenomenon uh clint with men uh i've
seen it and i i really hope that i don't
get to this point in my life but
men seem to get to an age where they
just think when i'm eating i'm gonna get
most of the food around the sides of my
face and i just won't really care about
it and billy has reached that point he
didn't used to be like that when i first
met him during lord of the rings he
never had stuff all over his face and
now
it's awful he gets stuff all over his
face and just leaves it there i think
you just don't you don't seem to care
anymore i don't and i missed a piece of
my beard today clint and uh it's went
gray and i keep thinking it's a piece of
white something on the bottom of my chin
so i've been rubbing it
i wish i had a napkin for you but i
don't well hold on
yeah right
right okay i'm gonna have one more bite
before we start giving it me too me too
nice it's very nice that johnny make
this for us wasn't it yeah well done
actually john i would well i'm not gonna
critique it yet john but you know me and
spice are like a little chili pepper but
kind of um
i don't know why but it sort of gives me
the book um makes me feel like
i'm i might be sick [ __ ]
this might bring down the scores
slightly
yeah i'm gonna do it anyway are you
gonna do a little bit of a blurb bills
don't know what else is interesting
about this i mean it's my name
john's giving us pages and pages over
here
i mean is it 2003. i don't know if it's
because you do retro gaming he wanted to
do retro history of cheese one of the
sentences here starts before world war
ii i was like what is that about cheese
right here is when in 1899 the editors
of boston cooking school magazine
editing john editing
john
wait a minute hold on let's in 2003
we've got to there was a pimento cheese
invitational
in oxford mississippi there was 300
entrants my goodness geez oh i'll read a
little bit here this is interesting
pimento cheese has now been transformed
into a sort of spicy all-purpose
condiment that can add an instant
southern touch to just about any dish
chefs stuff quail with it tuck it inside
of omelets slather it between two fried
green tomatoes
or make modern pan southern snacks
creations never seen in the 20th century
south the basic sandwich is still the
best way to enjoy pimento cheese today
if you want to get really fancy slice
off the crutch
cut the breads in diagonals which means
you get more bread i remember i told you
interquarters to create little tiny
triangles stack them high on top of each
other lay them out in a buffet line and
watch them disappear john that was
charming absolutely so
so basically everywhere you go around
where you live clint and and you went to
some days for lunch there was going to
be
some of this pimento cheeses should we
get a close-up absolutely like vomit and
would i mean
i s
we haven't
we haven't given it is it scores yet but
dom
it's not my favorite thing i've ever
eaten well if it makes you uh almost
vomit every time you try it i would say
yes definitely drop down in scores but
let's let's score it because
i think it's a surprising thing actually
i quite like it i've had three bites
i've had four but every is is
activating my gag reflex it's that's
been in the fridge
i think it may be getting worse
that
that would if it was at room temperature
maybe slightly baked in the sun a little
drippy
let's give it some scores flavor and or
taste out of ten
i'm um
it's a strange mm-hmm it's so mysterious
like it's not a it's not a nice taste
but i i go back to it you know i feel
like i feel like a dog licking beetroot
you know when you're kind of like oh i
don't like that but i'll keep coming
back to you do we think that it would
give you really bad breath well
definitely give you bad breath yeah like
a horrible um a mature
charred kind of taste in your mouth yeah
like an old uncle
who like boiled eggs and cigars oh god
he sounds awful is that uncle tony
oh god right well tastes like taste no
i've i can only give her a four i can
only get because i like cheese i like
peppers i like cream cheese but and i
like john
but whatever we like the four of them
together has just created something
truly yeah it's monstrous well i'll give
it a three it's dropped three okay well
i'll give it a four then cause i think i
like it a little bit more than you now
this is where it's in trouble aesthetics
the look of the
beast it looks like something
that a cat has uh thrown up in an
alleyway and john quite
quite magnificently has placed it in
a green
plastic container which i don't think is
helping much have you seen the exorcist
you know that moment where
the little girl goes i've got a secret
to tell you what's your secret what is
it well the secret was i'm gonna vomit
all over your face it looks it looks
like that right
aesthetics is low scores for me i'm
giving it a 1.5 yeah aesthetics i mean
there's colors that shouldn't be
together isn't it and now i can only
give a a
a 2.7 and like you said as well in a
green bowl in a green bowl a green black
green and then usefulness well this is
where it's going to jump up actually for
me because what could you do with a
pimento cheese that you couldn't do with
other cheeses
what would you do with this
well the spreadable nature
i mean you could spread it on anything
really couldn't you meat yeah fish
salmon let me try it with a cracker i'd
like it a dollop and slab it onto
anything you need that needs just a
little more cheese a little more well
you know what i think would benefit from
it is you know those you know those are
you all right no he's not liked it let's
back that out first time in the show up
to now that he's actually spat something
out he's rejected it physically the
cracker is worse than the cheese yeah
the crackers taste like chemicals don't
it does doesn't it it tastes like awful
it tastes like licking an old xerox
machine or something yeah we don't like
that but you know i was thinking with
this what this needs i think well i got
is a little bit of sharpness or maybe a
little vinegar so maybe those pickled
fish do you know like like caffilter
fish or maybe even a boccarone from
pleasure thank you from spain that
dipped in it might actually uh help yeah
it needs a zing a zing exactly i'd like
a little bit more chili pepper in there
but that's just a personal thing can i
take it to a football game in a kind of
refrigerated uh ice pack thing probably
so it's difficult because i'm saying i
don't like the flavor i don't know i
don't think i like how it looks but i
feel as if i could use it in a lot of
things yeah because so does it get high
yeah i think well you have to you have
to take each
voting system on its own merits and
versatility has nothing to do with the
taste it's how many ways can you use it
i think it is quite versatile okay then
tom i think it's versatile as well
i'm going to have to give it a but
don't let the taste come in don't let it
all right all right physically chucked
it up onto your plate
eight point two good yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna say about the same i'll give it a
i'll give it an eight for versatility
it's a low scoring and and i feel bad
but you know we've got to be an honest
an honest podcast and i don't like to
bring down anything that john's done and
he spent time making that and that's i
think that's fairness he could have went
out and just bought something from a
store but he made us something but he
made us something haters
so yeah you have to be honest right
absolutely i mean i would expect no less
if i if i was around north carolina and
i was going to people's houses and that
was on the table i probably wouldn't
take much of it unless it was with a
nice
sharp
vinegary figgery fish but imagine you
went to like someone's party and it's a
hot summery day and this had been out on
the counter for
a few hours and when you went to great
get it
separated so you've got like a very thin
see-through
viscous liquid kind of just pouring off
the bottom of it i think that's kind of
food poisoning hell am i making you feel
better or worse worse
sorry billy sorry we should move on hey
clint
thanks for bringing something so
disgusting to the show thank you very
much very well very welcome
before we let you go please let everyone
know where they can see your uh channel
and what you talking about old games and
all computer systems including the
dragon 32
where can they see that and primarily uh
i am on youtube so just search for lgr
on there and uh you'll find me there
that's where all of my content goes
otherwise it's just uh lgr on twitter
and facebook everywhere else but yeah
youtube videos i try to get one of those
every week and it's always something
different so it could be a computer one
day a game the other day or sometimes
i'm just looking at an old answering
machine or something like that so yeah
it's a it's a brilliant channel which
harkens back to i think more simpler
days with computers where instead of it
being headsets and mouse mats and you
know all these kind of newfangled stuff
it's just you maybe a bag of wine gums
and you just try to shoot an alien craft
exactly just me and you holding onto
each other's joysticks just going like
hell at each other oh yeah yeah
clint it's been fantastic having you on
thanks a lot for um all of your
wonderful uh tips and advice about how
to be a gamer in the 24th centuries
near enough tom thank you very much
glenn that was brilliant well i hope to
see you back in the friendship onion
soon all the best mates see you clint
bye-bye bye see ya bye
well there we are tom no i was saying do
you feel well after that sandwich i
don't feel 100 to be honest it's sat
around about here i'm always nervous
about foods that don't want to make
their way directly to the stomach they
want to sit in the throat just saying
would you like to bring that back up or
would you like to take it downwards i'd
like to take it downwards at this point
yeah it's better i mean it's halfway
down it may as well do the full path and
get itself out of there it wasn't the
greatest but that's what makes the world
go round in terms of a billion dollar
meet the world we don't always want to
be uh eating and drinking things that we
absolutely love sometimes we just want
to be eating and drinking curiosities
and with that in mind at some point in
the not too distant future really
we will be drinking a famous liqueur
from chicago called malort which i'm
reliably informed tastes like cat's piss
we'll be doing that soon anyway
it was a good show
really took me back to 1983
cran hill
in glasgow scotland me sitting there
just playing my atari i loved it it was
fantastic to see that little twinkle in
your eye when he remembered or reminded
you of the name is it the dragon 23 the
dragon 32 32 oh it was backwards yeah
and if you want to get me for my
birthday uh gallagher machine i'd love
that john that's the you the viewer not
the you the host no you don't oh that's
a shame well listen thanks a lot for
tuning in hey don hey i love this new
billion dom eat the world set me too i'm
loving the new studio i love the new
studio too but it means that we have a
new address so if you want to send us
something the new address is below don't
send it to the old address we won't get
it no we won't so if you've got anything
to send send it to the new address
you'll see it below wherever it is
you're watching show notes
and uh we'll see you next week it's true
on the friendship onion
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your boy's the baby you're my pearl